wir können uns ein stück mut leisten
aber wir müssen vorsichtig bleiben sagt
die bundeskanzlerin an einem tag der für
deutschland vieles ändert kitas schulen
restaurants sollen mehr und mehr öffnen
und und länder sagen aber auch das virus
ist nicht besiegt
rettung für eine fast verlorene saison
die erste und die zweite bundesliga
können in anderthalb wochen wieder
starten allerdings vor leeren rängen und
wirtschaftlicher schock für europa die
korona pandemie stürzt die eu in die
schwerste rezession ihrer geschichte
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
mittwoch guten abend ihnen ein es wird
einiges leichter
in unserem corona alltag aber es bleibt
auch wichtig vorsichtig zu sein dass es
die zusammenfassende überschrift heute
die konferenz der ministerpräsidenten
der bundesländer mit der bundeskanzlerin
hat eine reihe von ergebnissen gebracht
die länder bekommen mehr
eigenverantwortung
es soll eine art notbremse mechanismus
geben auf regionaler ebene
im gegenzug aber auch mehr lockerungen
hier ist der überblick
alle geschäfte egal wie groß dürfen
wieder aufmachen dann stichwort schulen
normalbetrieb bleibt undenkbar aber
etwas unterricht sollen alle schüler bis
zu den sommerferien bekommen
an den kitas soll es mehr notbetreuung
geben gerade für kinder die besondere
förderung brauchen
der profifußball kehrt zurück ohne
publikum ab mitte mai sportvereine
dürften wieder trainieren nur draußen
und an der luft und mit abstand aber die
kontakt regeln bleiben generell bestehen
und sobald die infektionen irgendwo
bedenklich ansteigen gibt es zunächst
regional wieder neue beschränkungen
patricia wiedemeier fasst die
politischen entscheidungen heute
zusammen wesentlich länger als geplant
wurde heute diskutiert vor allem wohl
über das vorpreschen zahlreicher
ministerpräsidenten in den letzten tagen
nun also gibt es weitere öffnungen
masken und abstand pflicht gelten weiter
und das kontaktverbot bis zum fünften
juni mit einer lockerung angesichts der
niedrigeren infektionszahlen soll der
aufenthalt im öffentlichen raum jetzt
nicht nur alleine mit den angehörigen
des eigenen hausstands oder einer
weiteren person möglich sein sondern
dass dies auch mit dem personen eines
weiteren hausstandes möglich sein wird
unter auflagen dürfen schulen ebenso wie
gastronomie und große geschäfte wieder
öffnen
in pflegeeinrichtungen und kliniken soll
jeder bewohner oder patient besuch von
einer kontaktperson bekommen dürfen
sollte es jedoch mehr als 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
geben zurzeit gibt es das im kreis greiz
und in
stadt rosenheim dann muss sofort
gehandelt werden aber nur regional diese
notbremse es ist sozusagen die notfall
police wenn man dann rechtzeitig einen
statt und zwar regional können wir die
regionalen pandemieplänen und damit mehr
personal mehr tests mit mehr containment
ford kann ausbreitung verhindert und
damit auch verhindert werden dass erneut
locker und für das ganze land notwendig
ist den flickenteppich der letzten
wochen dass jedes land für sich
entscheidet wann was geöffnet wird den
wird es aber auch weiterhin geben das
kann man föderale vielfalt nennen aber
zudem auch dazu kommen dass die
massnahmen regional sehr unterschiedlich
ausgestaltet sind
für die opposition sind die weiteren
befugnisse der länder nicht sinnvoll
allerdings haben die letzten wochen ja
gezeigt dass die unterschiedlichen
maßnahmen nicht und damit begründbar
waren sondern dass da er ein wettstreit
stattgefunden hat wer am meisten öffnet
und das finde ich eher kritisch
angesichts niedriger infektionszahlen
könne man sich ein stück mut leisten
wenn man dabei vorsichtig bleibe so die
botschaft der kanzlerin heute so auf die
einzelnen punkte gehen wir gleich noch
mal viel genauer haben aber erst
kontrolle banerjee in berlin mit der
polit analyse haluschak und alaa da ist
jetzt viel verantwortung bei den ländern
kann man sagen angela merkel hat das
management sozusagen abgegeben kann man
vielleicht sogar sagen nicht unbedingt
aus freien stücken aber sie hat es
abgegeben und sicher nicht ganz aus
freien stücken sie hat ja immer klar
gemacht dass ihr zwei dinge besonders
wichtig sind das ist zum einen gewesen
die einheitliche und verständliche
entscheidung von bund und ländern und
zum anderen ein besonnenes vorgehen
beides ist ihr in den letzten tagen
zunehmend von den ministerpräsidenten
durch eigene regionale entscheidungen
aus der hand genommen worden und heute
gab es eben die flucht nach vorne
die verantwortung liegt jetzt komplett
bei den ländern und nur die allerletzte
notbremse wenn irgendwo regional das
virus noch einmal aufladen sollte die
liegt noch beim bund also das bedeutet
ja dieses land deutschland wird sehr
unterschiedlich in die eröffnungsphase
gehen müssen wir damit leben dass wir
bis auf weiteres quer durch deutschland
lauter regeln haben die man sich jetzt
wirklich kaum merken kann
ja genau so sieht's aus wenn man sich da
an
was die ministerpräsidenten schon heute
nachmittag an eigenen maßnahmen bekannt
gegeben haben dann ist das eine vielzahl
auf die sich jeder einzelne dann wird
konzentrieren müssen was gilt für mich
jeweils in meinem bundesland oder in der
region in die ich reisen möchte die
bundesländer gehen jetzt mehr risiko ein
zu gunsten von bildung zu gunsten von
wirtschaft schlicht zu gunsten von etwas
mehr normalität und jeder einzelne wird
jetzt darauf achten müssen wie welche
regeln gelten für mich und wie kann
nicht diese regeln einhalten das ist der
preis den wir jetzt alle gemeinsam dafür
zahlen dass wir etwas mehr freiheit in
dieser schwierigen krise genießen dürfen
ich hoffe alle vielen berg und wie
versprochen gucken wir jetzt auf die
details bei den einzelnen punkten und
beginnen mit der betreuung für die
kinder in den kitas die langsam wieder
öffnen erst mal überall die notbetreuung
ausweiten und je nach bundesland auch
noch weitergehen sollen wie läuft das
konkret wie funktionieren die
vorbereitungen anna du damit mehr ab
montag dürfen an diesen tischen wieder
kinder malen und basteln bringt die kita
in rheinhessischen haag sein wird ihre
notbetreuung aus weil wir überarbeiten
im moment unseren aktuellen hygieneplan
corona bringt uns viel disziplin
erfordert viel disziplin viel kontrolle
wir werden sehen wie wir das in der
praxis auch mit kindern beleben
noch stehen viele gruppen räume leer und
200 kinder spielen und toben hier
normalerweise jetzt sind nutzlos in der
not betreuung kinder von eltern in
systemrelevanten berufen oder von allein
erziehenden ab montag sind es dann 25
kinder in kleineren gruppen und mit mehr
hygiene maßnahmen für die kita eine
herausforderung die eltern haben sich
wohl mehr erhofft
ich weiß dass auch sie den vorschriften
und
den bekannten gründen schwierig werden
wird aber irgendwie muss man lösung
gefunden werden das langsam auch wieder
die ganzen kinder in den alltag zurück
kommen können und auch die familien
wieder entlastet werden
ich finde es muss jetzt was geschehen es
muss jetzt irgendwie familiengerecht für
die familien gedacht werden eine reine
notbetreuung reiche nicht so die
elternvertreter das bildungsrecht des
kindes dürfen nicht vom beruf oder der
situation der eltern abhängen
es wird darum gehen so schnell wie
möglich provisorische zusätzliche räume
zusätzliches personal ins system zu
bringen damit wir ein möglichst rascher
zeit auch allen kindern wieder eine
umfassende betreuung perspektive bieten
können wie genau die neue krone realität
in den kitas aussehen wird darüber
entscheiden jetzt die bundesländer
besonders hart getroffen sind cafés
restaurants hotels lange mussten sie
ohne perspektive auskommen jetzt ist die
da heute hat das kabinett beschlossen
dass die mehrwertsteuer auf speisen für
ein jahr gesenkt wird und es gibt
konkrete fahrpläne wie gastronomie und
tourismus wieder öffnen können und zwar
ausdrücklich je nach bundesland
unterschiedlich steffen lobenstein im
schatten von goethe und schiller in
kaffee trinken was essen das geht ab
heute in weimar wieder die stadt in
thüringen erlaubt gastronomen die
openair nutzung also im freien tische
und stühle können aufgestellt werden und
damit der abstand auch gewahrt wird sind
öffentliche flächen sogar frei nutzbar
freude
befreit und er gesund finde ich es
einfach ein schönes gefühl man sieht wie
glücklich die menschen irgendwie sind es
auch ein schönes gefühl von lebensfreude
wieder und ich freue mich wieder raus
gehen zu dürfen
zwei stühle pro tisch sind gestattet
hinterher muss desinfiziert werden
und es gilt selbstbedienung erarbeitet
haben das konzept innenstadtverein und
stadtverwaltung zuversicht nun bei den
gastronomen die mitte märz zu sperren
mussten
es geht vorwärts muss auch sehen dass
unsere leute ja wir haben fast 25
angestellte müssen wir suchen wir weiter
arbeiten
die entscheidung wann und wie geöffnet
wird treffen die länder einzeln je nach
infektions lage
das gilt auch für hotels pensionen und
ferienwohnungen auch in hannover in
niedersachsen wo es am montag dann
losgehen soll noch viele fragen
[Musik]
drinnen oder draußen bewirtschaften
bedienung oder nicht alles fragen die
noch zu klären sind der erste schritt
für die gastronomie ist getan
wann aber das normale geschäft wieder
kommt kann bisher keiner sagen und das
nächste große thema der sport da haben
wir im moment noch sehr wenige
möglichkeiten radfahren das machen jetzt
viele und joggen alles möglichst mit
abstand vielmehr ging bisher nicht und
auch von den profifußballern bei den
stadion seit längerem nichts mehr zu
sehen
doch die bundesliga drängt schon seit
wochen auf die fortsetzung ihrer saison
dazu gibt es jetzt grünes licht aus
berlin ab mitte mai mit spielen ohne
zuschauer
michael pfeffer
das okay für den liga neustart gilt
ausschließlich für profispieler ohne
publikum lediglich vor dem fernseher
werden fans die entscheidung über
meisterschaft sowie auf- und abstieg
verfolgen können das dfl konzept hat
überzeugt wenngleich erst nach
kontroverser debatte ich weiß dass die
verantwortlichen in den
bundesligavereinen alles tun werden um
sicherheit zu erreichen
aber es sollten auch spieler die sich
unvernünftig verhalten auch mit
konsequenzen rechnen müssen denn es
haben sich nicht nur normale menschen an
alle hygienemaßnahmen zu halten sondern
auch diejenigen die sehr viel verdienen
sollte sich herausstellen dass das
konzept nicht funktioniert glaube ich
wird es zu konsequenzen kommen und das
wiederum kann die dfl das wiederum
können auch die vereine nicht wollen
denn uns ist heute noch mal gesagt
worden wird die saison nicht zu ende
gespielt werden wir mit insolvenzen von
profiverein rechnen müssen
auch freizeitsportler dürfen allerdings
nur draußen wieder loslegen unter
auflagen werden plätze spielfelder und
gewässer freigegeben ein bewegendes
signal im doppeldeutigen sinne für sport
deutschland zum einen wir kommen raus
aus dem stillstand und dürfen uns alle
gemeinsam wieder in bewegung setzen
zum anderen auch emotional bewegend für
all diejenigen die im sport
verantwortung tragen euro die sport
aktiv treiben in sachsen rollt schon der
ball aber mit notwendigen ansagen
[Musik]
training ist endlich wieder möglich
schön auf die abstände achten markus
haben beobachtet dass alles bei der
deutschen fußball liga in frankfurt
markus das ist jetzt die erste profiliga
weltweit wieder an den start geht soll
das auch ein zeichen sein an all die
anderen ja die heutige entscheidung hat
schon große signalwirkung schließlich
war der deutsche profifußball die
einzige wirtschaftsbranche die in
medizinische forschung investiert hat
ein ausgeklügeltes hygiene konzept
vorgelegt und vor allem nicht um
staatshilfen gebeten hat und die gesamte
sportwelt schaut natürlich auf die
bundesliga ich weiß die britische
premier league hat sich das konzept
besorgt will ähnlich wie die bundesliga
agieren
sie entscheidet am montag und die dfl
will morgen schlussendlich entscheidend
wann es dann tatsächlich wieder losgeht
ob am 15
oder am 22 so wie ich höre sind die
meisten vereine für das frühere datum
nur mainz und bremen sind dagegen sie
wollen eine längere vorbereitungsphase
auch die dfl will lieber früher als
später spielen auf jeden fall der
deutsche profifußball atmet auf es ist
eine entscheidung pro bundesliga aber es
darf auch nichts wirklich gar nichts
schiefgehen
ansonsten ist der kredit des deutschen
profifußballs schnell verspielt sagt
markus haben in frankfurt herzlichen
dank grundlage für alle entscheidungen
bleiben die zahlen dieser corona
pandemie und da setzt sich der positive
trend fort etwa bei den neuinfektionen
über die vergangenen sieben tage
gerechnet haben sich durchschnittlich
etwas über 1000 menschen pro tag neu
angesteckt insgesamt sind in deutschland
mehr als 167.000 corona fälle durch
tests bestätigt gut 137.000 davon gelten
inzwischen als geheilt 6993 menschen
sind in zusammenhang mit quid 19
gestorben
ab wann ist wieder was erlaubt darum
geht es auch in einem zdf spezial gleich
nach uns und in der zdf- heute- app
können sie außerdem noch mal in ruhe
nachlesen worauf sich bund und länder im
detail geeinigt haben
ein etwas anderes bild in spanien dort
müssen sich die menschen auf zwei
weitere wochen mit strengen ausgangs
beschränkungen einstellen die
minderheitsregierung von
ministerpräsident pedro sanchez hat sich
mit kleineren oppositionsparteien
geeinigt den notstand bis zum 23 mai zu
verlängern
am wochenende hatte die regierung die
regeln zwar etwas gelockert sie sind
aber immer noch strenger als sie bei uns
in deutschland je waren
in spanien haben sich nach den usa
weltweit die meisten menschen mit corona
infiziert mehr als 25.000 menschen sind
bislang gestorben
europas wirtschaft legt eine
vollbremsung hin und die worte die heute
aus brüssel zu hören sind könnten
drastischer kaum sein
die europäische union sieht sich in der
schwersten rezession ihrer geschichte
und spricht von einem ökonomischen
schock kroner werde der eurozone einen
wachsenden schuldenberg und steigende
arbeitslosigkeit ein brocken aus brüssel
stefan leifert was der
wirtschaftskommissar zu verkünden hatte
hätte eigentlich größeres publikum
verdient gehabt doch weil auch brüssel
noch in corona bedingten videomodus ist
sind die ränge leer als paul gentilini
die historisch schlechten
wirtschaftsdaten verkündet es ist jetzt
ziemlich klar dass die eu gerade in die
schlimmste rezession ihrer geschichte
eingetreten ist
um 7,5 prozent könnte die
wirtschaftsleistung der eu dieses jahr
abstürzen
auch arbeitslosigkeit und
staatsverschuldung steigen dramatisch so
groß die krise so groß aber auch die
unterschiede
am schlimmsten betroffen griechenland
mit einem minus von fast 10 prozent am
wenigsten polen minus 4,3 der süden
europas leidet deutlich stärker
griechenland italien spanien frankreich
kranken schon vor der krise und sind nun
härter getroffen viele nordeuropäer
kommen mit einer gebremsten tal vater
von auch deutschland für deutschland
erwarten wir einen weniger tiefen
absturz als in den meisten anderen
ländern
es wird sich auch schneller erholen und
zum vorkrisenniveau zurückkehren
doch der weg zurück nach oben wird
mühsam für die eu brüssel hat die korona
krise heute in düstere zahlen gegossen
diese prognose ist für die eu ein blick
in den abgrund in brüssel geht die sorge
um dass aus den wirtschaftskrisen
staatsschuldenkrisen werden könnten mit
dem zeug binnenmarkt und eurozone zu
sprengen um so lauter heute der appell
aus brüssel beim wiederaufbau europas so
geschlossen wie möglich zu bleiben sagt
stefan leifert in brüssel
schwer getroffen von der korona pandemie
ist nach wie vor brasilien doch der
präsident hält nichts von
schutzmaßnahmen und ausgangs
beschränkungen
jetzt kommen immer mehr hilferufe aus
den bundesstaaten im amazonasgebiet dort
steigt die zahl der toten
gefährlich ist auch die situation für
die ureinwohner sie leiden unter der
schlechten medizinischen versorgung und
sehen sich gerade jetzt von der
illegalen ab
holzen des regenwaldes besonders bedroht
christoph rath
es ist ein krieg der weitgehend im
verborgenen stattfindet im dickicht des
amazonas-regenwaldes diese bilder
erstmals exklusiv im deutschen fernsehen
zu sehen zeigen einen aktuellen
kampfeinsatz der brasilianischen
waldbehörde ibama sie jagen illegale
goldschürfer und holzfäller die in das
schutzgebiet indigener völker
vorgedrungen sind
sie entdecken eine riesige goldmine die
täter flüchten was sie hinterlassen
zeigt wie professionell ihr geschöpft
wurde das hier ist eine illegale
landebahn
es ist klar wer eine landebahn eröffnet
der hat grosses wirtschaftliches
vermögen in zeiten von corona steigt der
druck auf die indigenen völker sie bauen
zäune schotten sich ab
sie fürchten das virus und die gewalt
die die eindringlinge mit sich bringen
ein häuptling der carena die wir im
letzten jahr besucht haben ruft um hilfe
wir könnten von zwei tragödien getroffen
werden die erste die ansteckung mit dem
corona virus die zweite ein massaker sie
haben nun schon damit gedroht dass sie
uns umbringen werde wegen unseres landes
tatsächlich stellen die behörden in
diesem jahr erneut einen anstieg der
illegalen abholzung fest die regierung
tut wenig die truppe der ibama aber
schafft fakten die maschinen der
goldsucher brennen sie ab sie wollen ein
zeichen setzen
doch es kommt anders wenige tage nach
bekanntwerden der operation werden die
verantwortlichen entlassen
angeblich so schreiben zeitungen soll
sich präsident ball szenario ein freund
der agrar und bergbau lobby über das
beherzte vorgehen geärgert
es steht so schlecht wie lange nicht
mehr um den regenwald und die indigenen
völker und die korona pandemie versperrt
den blick auf das sterben im wald
brasiliens holzmafia thema heute abend
auch in einem auslandsjournal spezial
hier im zdf um viertel nach zehn jetzt
weitere wichtige nachrichten von heute
noch ist für viele nicht klar was aus
dem urlaub dieses jahr wird da kämpfen
tausende deutsche noch um geld für den
geplatzten urlaub im letzten jahr als
nämlich der reiseveranstalter thomas
cook pleite ging
seit heute können kunden eine erstattung
vom bund beantragen und zwar online die
deutsche thoma thomas cook hatte im
september insolvenz angemeldet weil die
ausfallversicherung begrenzt war blieben
viele kunden zumindest auf einem teil
der kosten sitzen
bei entsprechenden nachweisen gleicht
nun der staat den fehlbetrag aus ganz
anderes thema jetzt die angriffe auf
jüdisches leben in deutschland sind mehr
geworden extremisten verbreiteten hass
und hetze im netz und auf der straße
es sind besorgniserregende zahlen in
einer neuen studie über die roman
leskovar berichtet gut neun monate liegt
der angriffe auf juden zurück die
erinnerungen für den berliner rabbi bis
heute präsent von der synagoge aus war
er mit seinem sohn auf dem weg nach
hause leider waren wir attackiert
bespuckt beschimpft hier in die straßen
von berlin natürlich einen großen schock
neben solch schwerwiegenden angriffen
sammelt die recherche und
informationsstelle antisemitismus kurz
rias auch andere vorfälle schmierereien
beleidigungen beschädigungen vier
meldestellen gibt es jetzt bundesweit
2009 10 wurden für bayern berlin
brandenburg und schleswig holstein
1253 antisemitische vorfälle gezählt
ersten meldungen zufolge könnte die
polizeistatistik für ganz deutschland
2032 straftaten ausweisen rias geht
davon aus bundesweit würde ihre zahl
über den offiziellen angaben liegen sie
erfasst jenseits auch von den
strafbarkeit grenzen insofern wird sich
bei der zivilgesellschaftlichen
dokumentation immer ein wesentlich
größerer anteil als in den polizeilichen
zahlen abbilden der antisemitismus
beauftragte des bundes unterstützt die
rias arbeit das
bleiben werde dadurch sichtbar die
zahlen sind erschreckend aber sie
überraschen mich nicht wirklich
zunächst einmal ist ganz wichtig dass
wir diese zählweise überhaupt haben dass
wir ein besseres bild bekommen rapid
aichtal hofft zudem auf die richtige
schlussfolgerung aus den zahlen mehr
gesamtgesellschaftliches engagement im
kampf gegen antisemitismus
jetzt machen wir einen schnitt jetzt
kommt sozusagen der serviceteil in der
sendung es ist mittwoch zeit für die
lottozahlen und die lauten 5 19 31 34 43
47 superzahl 5 weitere gewinnzahlen
lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf seite
55 7
und dann gucken wir noch aufs wetter
sonnenschein gibt es ja schon reichlich
und jetzt wird es auch wärmer zu den
details gleich gunther tiersch claus
kleber hat das heute journal um 21.45
und fragen an bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder wir sind morgen wieder für
sie da und zwar sehr gerne aber erstmal
in allen ein angenehmer abend
[Musik]
mit namen liebe zuschauer sollte jetzt
deutlich wärmer bei uns dem hoch sei
dank dass sich über mitteleuropa liegt
denn so kann jetzt die warmluft von
spanien und frankreich langsam zu uns
kommen
auch in london wird morgen waren 20 grad
der anderen seite über osteuropa kommt
er die kühle luft wie sonst mittelmeer
voran deshalb morgen in athen genauso
warm wie in london rund 20 grad ja auch
bei uns wird es langsam milder die nacht
ist nicht mehr so kalt leichter frost
noch an den alpen bodenfrost allerdings
gibt es verbreitet
wir haben den klaren himmel mit ein paar
wolkenfeldern in norddeutschland und die
bringen dann auch tagsüber dichte
bewölkung erst einmal von der ostsee bis
nach brandenburg
nachmittags kommt auch dort die sonne
raus und wir haben diesen starken
nordwestwind immer noch an der
ostseeküste sonst sonnenschein teilweise
meist von einem wolkenlosen himmel und
deshalb ist die sonneneinstrahlung
extrem stark uv-index 67 auch da ist
sonnencreme durchaus noch ratsam die
temperaturen dann schon sehr angenehm im
süden das wird er deutlich wärmer 20 bis
24 grad auch im norden schon wärmer mit
etwa 15 bis 19 grad und die temperaturen
steigen weiter und erst am samstag gibt
es im südwesten erste schauer und
gewitter sonntag dann verbreitet über
süddeutschland und im norden wird schon
richtig cool ich wünschen noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut